donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't and the consequences of
that failure are severe
170 000 americans dead
millions of jobs gone while those at the
top taken more than ever
our worst impulses unleashed
our proud reputation around the world
badly diminished
and our democratic institutions
threatened like never before
now i know that in times as polarized as
these
most of you have already made up your
mind
but maybe you're still not sure which
candidate you'll vote for
or whether you'll vote at all
maybe you're tired of the direction
we're headed but you can't
see a better path yet or you just don't
know enough about the person
who wants to lead us there
so let me tell you about my friend joe
biden
12 years ago when i began my search for
vice president
i didn't know i'd end up finding a
brother
joe and i come from different places
different generations but
what i quickly came to admire about
joe biden is his resilience born of too
much struggle
his empathy born of too much grief
joe is a man who learned early on to
treat
every person he meets with respect and
dignity
living by the words his parents taught
him no one's better than you joe
but you're better than nobody
that empathy that decency
the belief that everybody counts
that's who joe is